very lucky to be able to speak to adam
peaty's parents caroline
and mark and bobby there's bobby in the
middle bobby is with them
as well hello to you both for all three
of you
hi hi hi bobby
let me talk to you and caroline and mark
instead how proud are you of your boy
immensely proud very proud yeah i
i heard uh mark i heard him talking
about you particularly mom as well of
course working in nhs but
mark he was set when he people say to
him how hard work it is what he does
he says my dad was a bricklayer brick is
a bricklayer and his job is much harder
than mine
you must be so proud of him
yeah i'm very proud yeah what he's
achieved he has tell me mom about when
you used to take him
was it was it you that used to take him
to the pool in the morning or was it dad
or did you take it in turns tell me
about that
no mark doesn't drive so it was just
left to me so what mark did
was unpack his bag get all his towels
and things got those washed and dried
and so he did that side of things and
prepared his food
i did all the driving in and around work
so
but you know we had good friends as well
that helped us
with some of the runs too so it was a
team effort
mark when did you realize that he was
going to be amazing and a goal medal
winner
i don't think i did i didn't realize
really
like he loved competitive swimming um
and then
he went he had um that was through dove
valley but he needed some more um open
meets
so when he went to derby um i still
didn't really think
you know anything more like he says i'm
going to be an olympic swimmer
i'm going to win the olympics says
you're right okay then
you you try your best as you as any
parent would
um and then we just went from there
really
and then he sort of dragged me along
rather than me dragging him
you know it was all on adam's back that
you know like come on mum come on
so he sort of took me along to
everything that we needed to go
and dad can i ask you i did it because
let me just ask daddy if i may caroline
sorry
what was it like this morning when you
were watching him on the telly rather
than being there i think you could go in
2016
didn't you but you you couldn't go today
yeah
no it was uh it was quiet it was only
three of us
but it was fantastic uh
when he got gold it was a quiet house
wasn't it
it was yeah yeah yeah and have you been
quiet
have you spoken to him no no
uh have you um he's messaged me this
morning because i messaged him
to tell him how immensely proud we are
and you know you know and enjoy
well we said to him be pride to the race
to enjoy it
um and then afterwards i just said that
you know we're really proud of you
really love you
and then he's messaged me and you know
said you know thank you
um and he said it you know um i
mentioned all about the pressure i said
even we felt it this time
um on you know for the sake of him um
and he said he'd felt it this time it
was hard so
this achievement's even more you know
it's greater than what
what i originally thought but it takes
ages for it to sink in it did
i think it's only just sinking in from
the 2016 show any pressure does it
no he doesn't know normally no
so he says mom that he felt the pressure
more this time than he had previously
yes i think so because like their
expectations
like he's going to get gold i would hate
to be on in
his shoes i really would you know
because i'm quite relaxed i'm thinking
well you know he does what he does
and he'll do his best he always does his
best so
that's all i can ask of him you know
everything else is a bonus
but i know he'd work and i knew he
worked so hard for this
and especially with the limits of covid
as well
and it's been a challenge with the baby
as well of course he's got a little boy
george the baby um he was talking about
how difficult it was
to be able to train and also be a dad i
bet
i'm guessing uh grandma and grandad have
been taking up some of the slack have
you
um not really no because of covid with
because of his risk of infection
um that airy and uh maybe has taken most
of the
the you know the thing with george we've
gone up when we can
um but like i say because of the
restrictions of covid
we've always had to do a lateral flow
test before wherever we've gone to see
adam at all you haven't seen him much
have we no not these
last few months that's a shift before we
go out yeah and to let him
it is a shame because we've missed out
on george as well yeah
hopefully we're not on our own are we
there's lots of people that have done
the same
yeah hopefully that'll get better in the
in the weeks to come
mark caroline how are you going to
celebrate when he comes home
i think he's thinking about um having a
barbecue at his house
now he's got his new house he's got
plenty of space for lots of people so
um that's how we all celebrate i think
looking forward to it dad what would you
do give him a big hug or are you more of
a handshake man
we'll give each other a rug when we when
we catch up
oh lovely lovely you must be super
proud tell me tell me briefly before i
let you go
what happened this morning did you set
the alarm or did you stay up all night
say we got to put a half past two but
this time i've sort of strained it till
um quarter to sorry my my eyes are
watery
um i strained it till quarter to three
because i needed that sleep
um and then we just got up and watched
it but it was really calm i think i was
just
right back in the sofa um because i was
that nervous
my stomach just churns it doesn't matter
how many races he's done it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter whether it's
the olympics
um i still get nervous and my stomach
churns
yeah and what about you dad were you up
about the same time or were you pacing
all night waiting for your boy to get
into that pool
you you were asleep then just wake up
didn't you yeah i was asleep and then
wake up then
fantastic but mars will repay all this
i watch this yeah and then there he was
he's an olympic
champion again how amazing he's never
been beaten for seven years
do you think bobby has got what it takes
to be an olympic champion sometime in
the future
i reckon so but i don't think it'll be
swimming it'll be boxing won't it sweet
pea
he loves boxing bobby does lovely it's
the eldest one oliver
um that loves the swimming ah lovely
it's
lovely to see you both thank you i know
you must be elated and you've got so
many people to talk to so we really
appreciate you taking the time
to join us on sky news this morning
thank you